people have a successful company and
they lose touch with the product when
the time came to germinate their ideas
they were ready and poised unable to do
that you could have put a chimpanzee in
Silicon Valley in 1986 and they would
have been successful in the venture
business I don't have any of these
ornaments and plants that commemorate
investments or companies from yesteryear
I just think they're irrelevant there's
really only one thing that they care
about and that care is deep because
starting a business founding a company
is the hardest act in business imagine
if you're in your teens and you become
fascinated with something and nobody has
to the best of my knowledge has ever
addressed a graduating class better than
Steve did that day
he's a Welsh born venture capitalist
with Sequoia Capital in Silicon Valley
he's a former member of the board of
directors of Google he has an estimated
net worth of three billion dollars he's
Michael Moritz and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success people have a
successful company and they lose touch
with the product and making it making it
very very important for the company just
go back and you know there's all this
stuff that's been written about Apple
and Steve Jobs in in the last few months
is is well worth reflecting on because
this was a man who took over a company
that was essentially bankrupt in 1997
and he realized that the products that
this company was selling were
embarrassing they weren't doing anything
for the customer they weren't
distinctive they weren't special they
had nothing that captivated the interest
of the of the customer and for me a
Sequoia Capital it starts with our we
were a service firm not a pram it starts
with the service that we're providing is
it still relevant
for our for our customers who alone you
know entrepreneurs largely for a
products company I think people they
they just lose touch with lose touch
with the product I think it helps if you
try and enter an environment where you
think you can learn a lot and whether
that's inside organization doesn't have
to be a company it can be some other
organization or around people that you
particularly admire that you can learn a
lot from and I think that just helps
expand one's horizons and also gives the
the individual a sense of what
excellence is really like if you pick
the right setting all the right set of
individuals and done right it's a
transformative set of experiences and
massively expands your horizons and the
sense that you have of all the wonderful
array of opportunities that lie in front
of you what do you believe set apart
people like Steve Jobs and Mark
Zuckerberg and Bill Gates apart from
their character they happen to be in
particular markets the personal computer
market for Steve Jobs and Bill Gates and
the internet for Mark Zuckerberg where
they had spent their youth and formative
years assembling knowledge that and a
deep interest in a particular topic that
the rest of the world didn't know very
much about so when the time came to
germinate their ideas they were ready
and poised unable to do that and
obviously then showed their mettle as
entrepreneurs because there were lots of
other people who were there at the same
time but who can who subsequently fail
whereas these people succeeded what is
your advice to a young person or not so
young person who would like to become a
venture capitalist the way you did how
should they go about doing it and should
they do it I think everybody should look
it's I there have been a few other
people who've been extremely fortunate
and lucky like I have and and I think
you know you could have put a a
chimpanzee in Silicon Valley in 1986 and
they would have been successful in the
venture business and and people just
have to follow their instincts and and
try and do what they think is going to
excite them excite them every day I
think probably it's more fun more
rewarding more demanding more taxing to
go and start a company as opposed to
being an investor in winter sure I don't
have any of these ornaments and plaques
that commemorate investments or
companies from yesteryear I just think
they're irrelevant
and it's about the past and is about it
I was a hewlett-packard the other day
walking around and they've got a museum
which is very touching it's really
interesting they've got all these old
oscilloscopes and computers and and and
you know these wonderful calculators
from 1971 fascinating they should not be
in the company if you're thinking about
tomorrow and they should be in a museum
someplace off campus or off off the
premises and that's the way that I think
about our own business I think and it's
what I was alluding to earlier I think
if we don't stay ahead of everybody else
I gradually it's the story of every
company that began to go down unless you
keep that fire up and keep worrying
about losing tomorrow you'll never reap
all the wonders and benefits that that
come from tomorrow which is why we try
to obviously you want to learn from the
past and not repeat the mistakes in the
past but you never from my point of view
want to roll in relish in past triumphs
you write about finding the people who
are obsessed mm-hmm how do you how do
you determine if somebody is has an
obsession it's um it's it's it's a good
point and it's one that you know I wrote
about with Wis Alex and in this book and
I think it's a characteristic of the
most successful entrepreneurs which is
that they certainly at the beginning of
their company and often for a very good
long time are able to shut out the rest
of the world and just devote themselves
to what they're really interested in
doing and shut off all the other
distractions because there's really only
one thing that they care about and that
care is deep and it's genuine and it's
the sort of thing that they go to bed
you know go to sleep thinking about and
they wake up in the morning thinking
that the best advice I ever got was a
set of three words which is follow your
instincts by which I mean if you've been
studying something at HKUST that
fascinates you enormous ly and you have
an idea about how you can build and
create something that maybe just a
little bit better than what's available
on the market go and do that and then
see where it leads I'm looking for your
reflections as a as a board member as an
investor is what you do what you advise
entrepreneurs I know when things aren't
working I always think of it and people
always very skeptical about this
response but
and because it but I always think about
it as if it's a very close family member
who's involved running the business it's
somebody who has worked incredibly hard
my because starting a business founding
a company is the hardest act in business
and people who haven't done it don't
really understand how taxing it is how
demanding it is the emotional costs and
consequences of it and so I always think
gosh if this was a cousin or a sister or
a brother running this business do I
think it's worth them spending the next
period of their life two or three years
of their life trying to salvage
something from what seems like an
incredibly distressing situation and if
the answer is yes then we're all in and
if it's no I will I will tell them that
but invariably
and those sorts of conversations come
around when you're thinking about
whether or not to sell a company you
know whether the most prudent thing to
do is to sell it or not sell it and on
the whole we really really dislike
selling companies and but there are some
situations where you think gosh the way
that that this person really that the
best thing for them is going to be to to
sell it and then move on to something
fresh and new and more promising imagine
if you're in your teens and you become
fascinated with something and you have
that period of time in your teens and
perhaps early twenties where you don't
have distractions you don't have a job
you don't have a family don't have
commitments and you can afford to
indulge your passion your passion can be
Bill Gates circa 1973 figuring out how
to
white programming languages for
microcomputers it could be Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak thinking about how to
build single board computers it could be
Chad Hurley or Steve Chen the founders
of YouTube trying to figure out how to
send video to one another it could be
Max Levchin this incredibly wonderful
ukrainian mathematician who was one of
the cofounders of PayPal trying to
figure out how to move money between
mobile phones well all of these people
in their particular spheres had thought
a lot more thought far more deeply about
that particular topic than any of the
rest of us they may not have known a lot
about other stuff they may not have
known how to read a chart of accounts or
how to think about marketing or how to
set up international operations or how
to build a logistic Center but all of
that stuff you can hire people to do
that what you cannot hire people to do
is to have the wonderful spark and
founding instinct and deep fascination
and abiding passion for a particular
topic the best advice that I could offer
anybody is to suggest that they go to
youtube and watch a very touching movie
and affecting address that Steve Jobs
gave several years before he died to the
students at Stanford University and
nobody has to the best of my knowledge
has ever addressed a graduating class
better than Steve did that day thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because will you laughs asked me to so
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know which of
the top ten rules had the biggest impact
on you and why leave it in the comments
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon